Film Courage: How many Thomas
Caine books have you written?
Andrew Warren, Author: Three novels and four
novellas. Two of those novellas I co-wrote
actually with another author and there's a
fourth book that has not been published yet
that's with an agent who I think
you asked about this before but he's
considering shopping it around we're
considering maybe signing with a publisher
and seeing what that might mean and
what might be out there in that avenue.
Film Courage: So what is that?
Andrew: It's about eight Thomas Caine books.
Film Courage: And why haven't
you tired of this character yet?
Andrew: I don't know I think
part of it is because I did keep his past
mysterious so there's always something else to
reveal I think if I had one of the things I wanted
to avoid was that I saw in a lot of thrillers
I call the resume where they'll be like oh we're
going bring in this guy, these ex-special forces
and he served five years in Libya and they kind
of go down as the whole thing and to me that
kind of takes the mysticism out takes something
away from it because I sort of feel like well
if the only thing that's special about him is
that he's a Navy Seal who did these things that
any Navy Seal did those things is the same
it's sort of so I wanted to kind of avoid
filling in like every little detail and and by
doing that I think it allows me to kind of find
new angles and new things that I find interesting
about him because there is a big black space in
the background so his his background is is a
mystery all we know is that he was betrayed
at a certain point in his life but is he a
mystery to himself or you don't go that far
into his thought well I try to go a little bit
into his thoughts but not too much because I feel
like in fact I originally when I first conceived
the series one thing I did change was I originally
was going to write at first person where you would
hear his thoughts and I realized I was like well
if I do that then I feel like i'm giving too
much away because you're always going to know
what he's thinking so a lot of time so I switched
it to third person and a lot of times when someone
asks him a direct really probing question I'll
have him just like look at the person and not
answer and I try to let the reader kind of
project what they think the answer might be
onto it so I really do make a concerted effort to
as much without sacrificing character and making
him someone believable and someone you can invest
yourself in I’d make a concerted effort to keep as
much of him in the dark as possible so that
because I think that allows the reader to
inject a little of themselves and their
opinions and their beliefs into his character
why is he doing this sort of like as an example
in that first the first book Tokyo black he's
he is sort of driven to help this girl and he's
it's never really explained why he sees a picture
of her and he just kind of from the very beginning
is inclined to help this girl and I remember the
editor kept saying I don't understand like why
does he want to help this girl so much why do
you want to help this girl so much and to me maybe
this was wrong but I just felt like if I went and
spelled it out that would sort of cheapen it I was
like I don't know he just feels this compulsion
but by leaving it open that's what I made the
novella about so in the novella that lot that I
gave away for free it's sort of outlined this
experience and I don't directly connect the
dots but you could read the novel and say oh well
maybe that's why he might be inclined to help this
person because here in this story he didn't
help a person in a similar predicament and this
is what happened so you could make that
connection or not so that's sort of the
way I try to handle that when you write a spy
thriller does the protagonist really change
it's tricky I don't think the protagonist has to
change per se but I do think some I think there's
two ways you can go and i've done both I think
they can change like in one area or in some area
or the world around them can change I think like a
character like james bond for example changes very
little throughout the books but the world around
him changes he stops things from happening or he
I mean really most heroic fiction is about
reasserting the status quo right like something
has gone awry and it's up to the air to set
things right and I think that's perfectly fine
I mean there's a million books and movies that
does Indiana Jones really change between those
movies I don't think he does but they're perfectly
entertaining so I don't think it's a requirement
but I do think when you're writing it's certainly
more interesting on the writer's side and I think
this might kind of go down to like what you're
saying about the reader's expectation and the
writer's expectation I don't think the reader
expects your hero to change necessarily book to
book but as a writer I think it's more fun if
you can sort of inject a little bit of change
and so that's why over the course of the first
three books like I mentioned in the fourth book
he's back to working with the cia and the course
of those first three books is sort of about that
change about him slowly kind of coming in from
the cold and learning how to trust again and
kind of rebuilding his life in essence and to
coming in from the cold so from being sort of
this outlier this like fringe character and now
being in this structured environment where he's
totally watched yeah probably has that and also I
think sort of believing in himself believing that
he can actually make a difference and do something
good because he starts off very bitter and angry
at himself like I said for the things he's done in
the past and there's a part of him that honestly
believes like if I get involved with these people
i'm just going make it worse for them like just
nothing good comes from me I mean and so I think
he's gradually kind of lifting himself out of
that I mean he sort of starts out a little bit of
kind of self-pity I mean he's he's living off the
grid he's kind of operating as a petty criminal
and just kind of surviving and so there's sort
of this theme in the first book about surviving
versus living he's not really living he's just
surviving so little things like that I but
they're not drastic changes I mean he's certainly
consistent throughout the four books and I that
to me that's enough to keep it interesting for
me and I don't think the readers really want him
to suddenly wake up and be a totally different
person or have a huge come to jesus kind of
thing I don't think that's what readers of that
genre looking for okay true or false question
here all major characters have strong motives
and that their own journeys aren't always
in alignment with any other character
all right let's do let's break that up into two
so all major characters have strong motives I
mean I don't I don't I feel uncomfortable saying
all anything I mean like I said I don't think
there's rules and i'm sure there's great stories
that might not pop into my head where they don't
have strong motives maybe like dazed and confused
that's a great movie I don't know i'd have to see
it again but I don't know if i'd say they have
really strong motives I think it's all that movies
almost about them sort of finding a motive like
by the time they get to the end but I think that
certainly most characters tend to and and I think
it's probably easier to construct a compelling
story around someone has a really strong motive
versus someone who doesn't like for example
close encounters the third kind I mean that guy
is obsessed like his entire life revolves around
figuring out like what happened and getting
to this point and he can't even explain why
but he's willing to give up his family and his job
and everything like that that I think it's I think
it's easier to construct that kind of story than
someone is just kind of ambling along and then
the second part is that their own journeys aren't
always in alignment with any other character sure
i'd say that's true I mean because that's flexible
right it says aren't always so maybe they are but
they certainly don't have to be how do you keep
track of your characters and all of their motives
I don't know I don't really have a hard time
with it I know some people make charts like
excel sheets like if you read a lot of books on
outlining say to for each scene you always want
to write down like the main character and what
their goals are for the scene I find for whatever
reason that just isn't an issue for me like I tend
to know what the character's motives are I just
maybe that's I don't know maybe that's just how I
kind of come up with the scenes from in the first
place but i've never really had a problem
with that like it's just sort of in my head
how important is that first opening page I think
it's certainly important I think people I don't
know I mean I guess it depends on your style
I mean I think some people really want that
amazing sentence that just hooks you I'll be
honest I don't tend to write that way I don't tend
to have that usually I think my openings are more
kind of setting a place and kind of drawing you in
I think one way or the other you need to interest
a reader but I think there's lots of different
ways of doing that so I think again you just have
to find what works for you but I think if you read
my books I don't think you would like read the
first sentence of any of them and be like that's
an amazing first sentence I think that just isn't
isn't my style okay so it's not it was the best
of times but I know who is it lee child says
that he like spends days like he'll rework the
first sentence over and over and over to to get
it to be just right I don't know I for me it's
more about the mood i'm establishing in that first
page than like getting that sends that really pops
but everyone's different and you have to
find what stylistic touches work for you.
Question For The Viewers: How common is it for
you to grow tired of the
characters you have created?